madame monsieur bonsoir
voici les titres que nous allons
développer dans ce journal l'arrestation
sans effusion de sang s'est tenue à
belgrade de slobodan milosevic accusé de
corruption il a été placé pour 30 jours
en détention préventive
la communauté internationale considère
que c'est une première étape nécessaire
mais qu'il faudra que l'ancien dictateur
répondent de crimes de guerre et contre
l'humanité devant le tpiy
dans cette édition nous retrouverons
direct jérôme ni notre envoyé spécial à
belgrade et la porte-parole du tribunal
pénal international à l'est florence
hartmann les licenciements annoncés chez
danone et marcel spencer provoque
émotion et colère après lionel jospin
qui parle de sanction pour délit d
entrave la gauche plurielle demande
davantage avec un vrai coup de barre à
gauche
amsterdam une première mondiale le
mariage de couples homosexuels autorisés
à adopter des enfants
la loi est entrée en vigueur aujourd'hui
et puis succès indéniable pour le
printemps des musées un millier
d'établissements ouverts gratuitement
leurs portes partout en france cette
initiative dont c'est la troisième
édition en france aura suivi cette année
dans 23 autres pays ainsi donc ce beau
jeune minot devils s'apprêtent à passer
sa première nuit en prison devenu maître
dans l'art du contre-pied l'ancien
dictateur qui a affirmé hier encore
qu'il ne se rendrait jamais vivant a
finalement été arrêté sans violence ni
effusion de sang la nuit dernière
tout laisse à penser que d'âpres
négociations se sont déroulées ces
dernières 24 heures et c'est ce matin à
l'aube que milosevic a gagné la prison
centrale de belgrade pour être entendu
par un juge d'instruction dans
l'après-midi résultats de cette première
comparution l'ancien président
yougoslave a été mise en détention
provisoire pour 30 jours
bernard lebrun jamais je n'irai en
prison vivant il vieillit depuis 5
heures ce matin
ultime bravade d'un président déchu
devenu
une nuit le détenu milosevic au petit
matin arrive l'avocat du grand homme sa
spécialité les serbes de bosnie jugé à
la haye devant le tribunal pénal
international
il était dans la voiture du prévenu
c'est plus en substance m toma fila
explique que slobodan milosevic n'a pas
été arrêté mais qu'il s'est rendu à la
justice de son pays nuance qu'est ce qui
a donc changé cette nuit pour que le
fort chabrol imprenable depuis 24 heures
se transforme en ville a ouverte
personne ne connaît la teneur des
négociations 4h40 en quelques minutes la
police procède dans le calme à
l'arrestation
un convoi de limousines fils alors
directement vers la prison pas d'image
du prévoux c'est alors qu'éclate des
coups de feu dans le parc de la villa
présidentielle expression de la colère
dire à un ministre des potiers doses
après le départ de son père la fille de
slobodan milosevic a été victime d'une
crise de nerfs à la mi-journée dans
cette voiture est arrivée à la prison le
juge kobryn à il a signifié à l'ancien
président qu'il était en détention
préventive pour un mois puis on est
passé au dossier plus tard dans
l'après-midi m fils à qui assistait à
l'audition a expliqué à la presse que
son client rejeté en bloc les
accusations portées contre lui mon
client a affirmé qu'il n'était coupable
d'aucune des accusations d'abus de
pouvoir et de détournement de fonds a
décidé de se défendre et de dire la
vérité va être fils là a annoncé qu'il
allait faire appel sur le mois de
préventive mais sans être dispo son côté
le ministre de la justice serbe vlada
mbathie tx a expliqué que la question du
tribunal pénal international ne serait
d'actualité qu'après l'adoption du noir
par le parlement sur la coopération avec
le tpiy
désir soir au palais présidentiel la
crise au sommet semblait oublier le
président kostunica et son premier
ministre zoran djindjic avait
semble-t-il bien décidé de tourner la
page
six mois après sa chute politique qui
après avoir tenu d'une main de fer le
pouvoir pendant près de 15 ans milosevic
est devenu un citoyen ordinaire
incarcéré à belgrade est accusé dans un
premier temps d'abus de pouvoir et de
corruption par la justice serbe
voici comment les belges les belgradois
réagissent est aujourd'hui à son
arrestation
richard binet alexandre à 8 chez patrick
des semis un dimanche ordinaire dans le
parc de calais magdane au centre de
belgrade
on y voit deux vieilles dames tenter
d'améliorer le quotidien en vendant
leurs modestes artisanat 300 francs par
mois de pension
il faut survivre il y en a a été médecin
pour l arrestation de slobodan milosevic
n'est que justice
travailler dans l'humanitaire
comme lui j'ai un petit fils mais
lorsqu'il était au pouvoir et ce qu'ils
se préoccuper de nos familles rue vézina
au café le plateau haut lieu de la
contestation à la fin des années 90
tiana a toujours milité contre milosevic
elle ne cache ni sa satisfaction et son
nationalisme c'est bien il est arrêté
il faut maintenant le jugé pour ses
crimes mais pas au tribunal de la haye
pourquoi parce qu'il faudrait juger
ainsi z begovic rouge marc sauvé la
croatie en mourant novi beograd une
cité-dortoir planté au bord du danube
trois cent mille personnes la chambre à
coucher de belgrade dit ses habitants
menad et yann à lille dans un petit
appartement où ils n'ont d'autres
loisirs que de regarder passer les
bateaux il nous amenait d'une guerre à
l'autre d'une misère à l'autre jamais le
meilleur toujours le pire il ne nous est
jamais rien arrivé de bon à nous les
jeunes c'est pour cela il doit être jugé
la majorité des belgradois ont accueilli
avec satisfaction
l'arrestation de slobodan milosevic pour
autant il ne souhaite pas forcément
qu'il soit extradé
mais qu'il soit jugé en yougoslavie pour
onze années d'un règne sans partage qui
a mené le pays à la ruine et en direct
de belgrade nous retrouvons notre autre
envoyé spécial de jérôme boeny que savez
vous ce soir des conditions de détention
de milosevic et comment va se dérouler
le calendrier judiciaire à votre
connaissance
oui béatrice je viens de rencontrer
l'avocat de slobodan milosevic m fils à
qui nous a expliqué que son client est
très très fatiguée comme lui d'ailleurs
ils n'ont pas dormi depuis quatre jours
et qu'ils étaient installés dans une
partie spéciale au premier étage de la
prison de belgrade une partie qui a été
ouverte pour la circonstance une grande
cellule avec huit lits et une salle de
bain pour l'ancien président milosevic
ou lui a droit à l'eau chaude alors que
l'ordinaire des prisonniers plus tôt
l'eau froide en revanche il a ni
télévision ni journaux il est coupé du
monde il a droit aux visites de sa
famille en fait essentiellement sa femme
mira markovic et sa fille qui lui
rendent visite chaque jour son avocat
espère qu'il obtiendra la visite aussi
de certains membres de son parti le
parti socialiste de serbie en ce qui
concerne la suite de la procédure
son avocat ne se fait aucune illusion
sur la demande de remise en liberté
il sera auditionné dans une dizaine de
jours quand les trois co inculpés dans
son affaire ont également été entendus
par le juge d'instruction
sion et le procès arrivera plus tard il
faut tout bleu des experts déterminent
si de l'argent a été envoyée à
l'étranger auprès du service des douanes
et s'il ya des comptes ouverts à
l'étranger quand on demande à m sila est
ce que ça va durer longtemps
il dit on n'en sait rien et fait un
geste pour dire qu'en tout cas ça sera
beaucoup plus long que le mois de prison
préventive déjà prévus merci jérôme
bunny de toutes ces précisions de
nombreuses réactions bien sûr
internationale à l'arrestation de ce
beau jeune milosevic parmi lesquels nous
retiendrons celle du président américain
qui considèrent qu'il s'agit d'une
première étape conduisant un procès pour
crimes contre l'humanité
quant à jacques chirac il se réjouit de
cette arrestation confirmant que les
autorités yougoslave ont fait leur choix
du chemin de la démocratie et du droit
justice doit maintenant être faites a
ajouté le chef de l'état
même si l'ancien président yougoslave je
rejette cet après midi toutes les
accusations portées contre lui il est
bien inculpé depuis vendredi dernier par
le parquet de belgrade d'abus de pouvoir
et de malversations il aurait détourné
des sommes considérables et pillé le
pays en puisant dans les fonds publics
un volet financier qui pour l'instant du
moins laisse totalement de côté les
charges qui pèsent contre l'ancien
dictateur accusé de crimes de guerre et
de crimes contre l'humanité et qui
devront rendre compte devant le tpiy
gérard québec
c'était leur heure de gloire ils vont
maintenant devoir rendre des comptes
car en treize ans de pouvoir slobodan
milosevic a construit un état mafieux et
qui dit mafia dit d'abord famille la
famille milosevic s'est enrichi grâce
aux trafics en tous genres
aidé par la guerre et l'embargo la
justice yougoslave reproche à slobodan
milosevic d'avoir empoché indûment 850
millions de francs
pas moi sans parler des crimes de guerre
je pense qu'il se jugeait d'avoir chez
nous parce que je signale que dix sept
mille pointe des serbe pour les crimes
de guerre qui a commis monsieur yves
rocher ont été remis à la justice de
serbie alors il faut d'abord qu'ils
répondent à notre pop up qu'après si
c'est nécessaire bien sûr il y aura une
coopération il ya toujours une
compilation avec la haie et je peux
imaginer qu'un jour il va finir et après
le père le fils marco qui s'est enfui à
l'étranger sportif ancien pilote de
course il se plaisait à dire qu'il
fallait être idiot pour ne pas gagné son
premier million avant l'âge de 21 ans
il s'est enrichi grâce à l'embargo
occidental en organisant le trafic de
cigarettes et d'essence
on dit d'ailleurs qu'il serait
responsable de l'assassinât d'arcane il
ya un peu plus d'un an
les deux hommes se seraient disputés le
marché de la contrebande et la sphère
aurait mal tourné arcane s'était fait le
champion de l'épuration ethnique en
bosnie à la tête de sa milice l'homme
symbolisait parfaitement ses guerriers
reconverti dans les affaires en arrêtant
l'ancien président yougoslave
la justice va devoir remonter toute la
chaîne des proches de slobodan milosevic
et décider ou non de son transfert à la
haye est précisément directe de lait
nous retrouvons ans florence hartmann
qui est porte parole du tribunal pénal
international d'amour forcément un
sentiment de satisfaction ce soir
milosevic est derrière les barreaux
satisfaction oui mais la cheville est
enfin arrêté
maintenant il s'agit de
le demandent aux autorités et aux arts
de le transférer à la haye nous en
verrons dans les jours prochains le
greffier du tribunal qui vérifiera que
l'inculpation et le mandat d'arrêt qui
existent contre lui lui elle lui a été
notifié par les autorités locales lors à
ma connaissance n'avait pas encore les
moyens légaux de persuader ou de
contraindre les autorités yougoslave de
livres et slobodan milosevic est ce que
c'est d'abord une question de calendrier
nous avons un dispositif légal pour
forcer les autorités yougoslave à
respecter leurs obligations
internationales parce qu'il s'agit d'une
obligation internationale de la
yougoslavie de coopérer avec le tribunal
mais également d'arrêter de transférer
tous les inculpés quelle que soit leur
nationalité
pour l'instant nous ne sommes pas dans
ce cas de figure nous attendons des
autorités yougoslave qu'elle réagisse
d'elle même c'est pour ça que nous
assurerons que le mandat d'arrêt a été
notifiée à l'inculper nous avons le
moyen de le faire à partir de quelques
temps quelques semaines par exemple
devant le conseil de sécurité nous
pouvons également demandé en vertu du
statut que les la juridiction nationale
soit dessaisi le temps du procès pour
crimes contre l'humanité devant le
tribunal de la haye lui madame hartmann
les autorités de belgrade ont toujours
dit qu'elle ne reconnaissait pas le
tribunal pénal de la haye
qu'adviendra-t-il donc il y a eu un
changement depuis
et les élections nous avons déjà eu une
arrestation sur le territoire serbe d'un
inculpé de bosnie herzégovine pour
génocide il a été transféré à la haye il
y à des progrès et je pense que cette
issue n'est pas complètement fermée si
les autorités sont complètement
obstruction nous pouvons réagir mais il
est tout à fait fondamental que
milosevic soit jugé pour son rôle dans
la guerre
il est inculpé pour le kosovo nous
enquêtons et prochainement nous aurons
une inculpation pour la bosnie et la
croatie
monsieur milosevic ne peux pas répondre
seulement de délit de corruption dans
son pays les deux procédures judiciaires
doivent coexister il est important pour
la réconciliation dans la région que
milosevic soit individuellement reconnu
responsable des crimes qu'il a commis
pour libérer le peuple serve de la
responsabilité collective cela est
fondamental aussi merci madame meurthe
man d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions l'un des grands thèmes sociaux
de la semaine à venir reste et restera
les licenciements annoncés chez marks
and spencer et danone qui ont
brutalement secoué l'opinion publique et
les politiques du coup dans la gauche
plurielle l'on réclame un coup de barre
à gauche il hier lionel jospin disait
vouloir garder le cap coûte que coûte il
n'évoquait que les sanctions parlant de
délit d' entrave cyrille devaud and
manque la méthode utilisée par marks &
spencer pour annoncer 1700 licenciement
n'a visiblement pas plu à lionel jospin
les responsables des magasins en france
ont été informés par la direction
britannique en même temps que la presse
et la bourse par un simple email le
gouvernement pourrait saisir les
tribunaux pour délit d'entravé dans la
sphère marks & spencer le comité
d'entreprise n'aurait été ni consultés
ni informés du plan social
si une procédure de délit d'entravé est
engagé le président de l'entreprise
risque jusqu'à un an de prison et 25
mille francs d'amendé mais en aucun cas
les licenciements ne peuvent être
annulées
pourtant les salariés ont reçus comme un
encouragement le soutien du premier
ministre
ils vont te aussi engager une procédure
c'est long malheureusement mais entre
temps malheureusement les collègues sont
là nous sommes sans emploi dans pas
longtemps
donc qu'est ce que fait gouvernement
justement par rapport à ça et se
conserve sur ce point justement pour
éviter que nous soyons à la rue et qu'on
puisse pour trouver très rapidement un
emploi
c'est également la question que l'on se
pose à lui zine lui de calais frappé de
fermeture par le plan social version
danone décourager les salariés attendent
plus que des mots du premier ministre
c'est bien mais ce n'est peut-être pas
encore c'est parce que il a juste dit
qu'il était content mais n'a rien fait
pour l'empêcher parce qu'ils ne jouent
pas au courant de ce plan lionel jospin
annonce est fière que le gouvernement
naviguerait tout droit avec un peu plus
de vent dans les voiles
les autres membres de la gauche
plurielle voit au contraire dans les
plans sociaux à répétition une
incitation à mettre la barre à gauche
nous pensons nous qu'il faut qu' il y
ait un changement de cap qui ne nous
semblent pas avoir été pris en compte
hier dans le séminaire gouvernemental je
pense qu'elle conte vernement tu veux
plus qu'on tentait de mots qui ressemble
à un aveu d'impuissance garder le cap
quand la majorité plurielle penche à
gauche voilà qui ne manquera pas de
faire tomber le gouvernement
un nouveau point des perturbations à la
sncf à la veille de la semaine qui
s'ouvre
quelques perturbations aujourd'hui qui
devrait se retrouver demain encore pour
la cinquième journée consécutive pour le
réseau tgv dans le nord trois trains sur
quatre et deux sur trois dans le sud est
pour les trains corail 1 train sur 2
dans le nord-est et deux sur trois dans
le sud est
enfin pour les ter à marseille 1 train
sur 2 et 2 trains sur 3 au départ de
lille metz nancy et dijon
enfin en ile-de-france encore quelques
perturbations et l'arrêt complet de la
ligne e du rer et un train sur trois sur
le réseau paris sud-est
revenons à présent sur cette information
que nous vous donnions hier concernant
le non lieu dont bénéficient les quatre
jeunes accusés d'avoir violé une femme
gardien de la paix dans le rer en 96 5
ans après les faits les suspects ont
donc été innocenté la justice soupçonne
même la jeune femme d'être mythomane
pascal de sebo sandrine dit elle la
vérité ce gardien de la paix âgé de 28
ans à l'époque des faits
dit avoir été battue et violée par
quatre hommes le 25 octobre 96 elle
regagnait son domicile après le service
dans un train de banlieue quelque peu
déserté l'agression dit elle a eu lieu
dans la raab basculer sur la banquette
arraché le sac et donc ensuite ils sont
tous arrivés et ça a commencé au
calvaire la police ne retrouvera aucun
témoin sandrine dit avoir regagné son
appartement choqué et s'être entièrement
désinfecté pas de traces d adn
et quand les enquêteurs lui présente les
visages de djamel idrissa d'elle et
mustapha 18 et 19 ans elle dit les
reconnaître à coup sûr je suis formel et
je resterai formel c'est certain simon
inquiété dans le trait c'est eux qui
étaient sur moi
les quatre hommes passeront plus de six
mois en détention provisoire ils ont
pourtant tous d alibi solide certes l'un
d'entre eux a avoué mais une enquête de
la police des polices révélera des
mauvais traitements à son encontre
près de cinq ans après les faits ils
sont désormais innocenté 50 c'est long
et la défense elle même reconnaît qu'il
fallait bien ça l'enquète de la police
judiciaire a été détaillé elle a permis
de vérifier la libye elle a permis de
procéder à d'autres investigations
parfois dans certaines affaires le temps
est utile il faut prendre son temps
sandrine a décidé de faire appel aucune
piste sur d'autres éventuelles violeurs
les enquêteurs doutent de l'existence
même de l'agression et parle d'une
supposée victime à la personnalité
déconcertante cdma reprendra devant la
cour d'assises de paris le procès de guy
georges l'occasion de nous intéresser à
ce dispositif mis en place par les
gendarmes est en cours d'élaboration
dans les services de police il s'agit
d'un fichier d'analysé criminelle pour
pister les tueurs en série la
gendarmerie a déjà le sien lana crime
les policiers près par le leur audrey
goutard rhénus posséder deux ans que
l'adjudant karl est plongée dans le
passé d'un redoutable tueur en série
l'homme est en prison depuis quatre ans
pour les meurtres de cinq jeunes femmes
mais pour l'adjudant la traque continue
rien n'est terminé
chaque jour avec son ordinateur il
rentre dans son logiciel anacrim
d'autres meurtres inexpliqués d'autres
disent pas
ici on est lucides et ils recoupent les
modes opératoires compare les lieux
cherche où se trouvait le meurtrier à
l'époque des faits résultat d'après anna
crimes le tueur n'aurait pas assassiné
cinq femmes mais au moins 20 de quoi
relancer les enquêteurs sur de nouvelles
pistes
vous avez ici tous les points de passage
de l'auteur avec éventuellement toutes
les informations qui peuvent être utiles
aux enquêteurs qu'ils sont reportés sur
cette carte
au fur et à mesure que l'information
nous est communiquée à travers les
dossiers
on commence à reconnaître ses habitudes
savons-nous style de pensée
en plus nous allons dès des spécialistes
des médecins des psychiatres mais les
institutions sont jalouses de leurs
prérogatives et seule la gendarmerie a
accès au logiciel anacrim pourtant les
policiers voient l'intérêt d'un tel
soutien
aujourd'hui nous avons le renfort de
l'informatique qui nous permet d'entrer
dans l'analyse du fait de la machine
beaucoup plus déments et sur tout et les
croisés et de faire en sorte qu'ils
aient de moins de trous le moins deux
hommes dont le moins deux hommes
inexplorés par l'anc est justement d'art
enquête en fait la police à son projet
de recoupements judiciaire le logiciel
chardon il devrait bientôt voir le jour
sa particularité il a été conçu par des
hommes expérimentés ceux de la brigade
criminelle pour le valider ils l'ont
testé sur un cas concret celui du tueur
de l'est parisien
et là où les policiers ont mis des
années à faire le rapprochement entre
ces deux meurtres chardon a donné tout
de suite la clé
il n'y avait qu'un seul et même tueur
dit georges la parité lors des élections
municipales un pari gagné 47 5% de
femmes siègent dans les conseils
municipaux
il est vrai que la loi a pesé un parfait
équilibre dans l'élaboration des listes
reste que si un élu municipal sur deux
est bien une femme
ce sont toujours les hommes qui dirigent
la plupart des grandes villes
il n'y a que 10 % de femmes maires comme
d'habitude ce sont les exceptions qui
confirment la règle comme dans certains
arrondissements de paris ou encore à
beauvais dans l'oise
des exemples choisis par laurence
ostolaza et alexandra beauvais
cinquante-huit mille habitants 24 ans de
règne socialiste auxquels a mis fin
caroline cayeux juriste de formation et
secrétaire départemental du rpr
les électeurs ont donc plébiscité le
changement incarné par cette militante
qui bat le pavé depuis des mois elle se
retrouve aujourd'hui à la tête d'un
conseil municipal de 45 personnes dont
22 femmes
pour caroline cayeux la parité c'est une
bulle d'oxygène mais aussi un gage de
crédibilité
le fait qu'on ne se soit pas rendu
compte du travail que nous faisions
c'est qu'on avait peut-être pas
forcément envie de prendre une équipe
très féminisés au sérieux ce n'est pas
le cas avant non c'était pas le cas
avant il n'y a jamais eu de femme mère à
beauvais parmi ces traits adjoint deux
femmes chargées de la famille de la
santé et de l'action sociale
si elles reconnaissent le bien fondé de
la loi sur la parité
elle avoue que cette loi n'arrive pas à
bout des préjugés masculin respecte et
je ne pense pas considérer peut-être la
différence entre les deux
à beauvais les femmes sont fiers de leur
victoire en provoquant l'alternance
elles ont écrit une page de l'histoire
de la ville paris 4e arrondissement
dominique bertinotti connaît bien la
mairie elle y est élue socialiste depuis
95 mais désormais fini le bureau exigu
lundi prochain il prendra officiellement
ses fonctions de maire pour constituer
son équipe elle a choisi autant de
femmes que d'hommes la parité parfaite
mais pour les plus jeunes ce n'est pas
vraiment une révolution
les personnes de ma génération pas
surprise la parité puisque dans les
écoles dans la vie de tous les jours
dans le sport la parité existe un
arrondissement de plus de 30000
habitants jusqu'à lors toujours dirigée
par un homme
lucien finel dernier miranda tu reçois
aujourd'hui dominique bertinotti
comme pour un passage de témoin entre
deux générations d'un monde politique à
l'autre c'est vrai que l'on vivait dans
un monde politique anachronique de ce
point de vue là donc c'est quand même
aussi beaucoup plus agréable de partager
je dirais une proximité avec des femmes
alors qu'avant on était très très très
peu nombreuses comme le 12e et le 17ème
le 4e arrondissement se prépare à
accueillir madame le maire
un coup de jeune politique qui ne
dispensera pas la mairie d'un bon coup
de peinture est bon si jordan hill les
funérailles d'un bébé israélien de dix
mois tuée par un palestinien qui visait
le quartier des colons des obsèques sous
haute sécurité quelques 2000 personnes
en colère faisait partie du cortège
funéraire
vendredi dernier le thé annonçait
vouloir menacer les sites touristiques
en espagne recommandant aux étrangers
d'éviter de s'y rendre
agnès vahramian et sylvain doba sont
allés à la rencontre de vacanciers qui
prennent au sérieux ces mises en garde
mais qui n'ont pour autant pas renoncer
à leur voyage
reportage dans cette station balnéaire
de la costa brava où a eu lieu un
attentat il ya trois semaines
c'était en bord de plage devant cet
hôtel 90 kg d'explosifs dans une voiture
l'attentât a fait un mort un policier
les touristes avaient été prévenus
évacué par téléphone le tour opérateur
espagnol a alors demandé à ses
vacanciers belges
s'il voulait toujours venir ici qu'ils
disent qu'ils viennent jamais de faire
la même grâce à caumont bombe de femmes
un passé commun venu le patron de
l'hôtel veut croire lui qu'il s'agit
d'une action sporadiques
choqué il est surpris mais nous du calme
de ses clients pour le moment on n'a eu
ni pas l'annulation
on a eu les mêmes en relation qu'on a
déjà gagné l'annulation de dernière
minute
et tout ça mais au contraire il ya
beaucoup de monde qui nous a téléphoné
pour pour nous dire qu'il va retourner à
notre hôtel rosas accueille quinze mille
touristes à la mi-saison 150000 chaque
semaine en été et ce week-end comme les
autres européens les français sont là
principalement à cadaquès la ville de
salvador dali la frontière est à 50 km
le tfc menace maintenu à distance et les
vacances qui sont programmés réservés je
veux partir
la plage de temps tellement belle et le
coin tellement super je crois que c'est
parce que
les gens de venir dans les lieux de
résidence des retraités hollandais ou
allemand on nous explique que la
vigilance est plus grande mais qu'il
n'est pas question de renoncer à ces
marina qu en bourse depuis dix ou vingt
ans avec ces attentats le thé avis bien
sûr les intérêts économiques espagnols
mais son message est aussi publicitaire
pour que l'europe toute entière n'oublie
pas la question basque situation en
tendues entre pékin et washington après
qu'un accrochage en plein ciel est
impliqué un avion militaire américain et
deux chinois
un avion de chasse chinois se serait
écrasé la guerre des communiqués que
nous raconte notre correspondant
permanent aux états unis etienne
leenhardt de voix si l'avion espion
américain avec ses quatre moteurs à
hélices et un gros radar sous son
fuselage
selon les chinois c'est bien l'appareil
américain qui aurait heurté un avion
militaire chinois dont le pilote est
d'ailleurs porté disparu selon les états
unis
l'appareil américain en mission de
routine avec 24 personnes à bord a été
intercepté et endommagé par deux avions
de chasse chinois
pas de blessé mais l'avion espion a dû
atterrir en urgence sur l'île chinoise
de hainan où des diplomates américains
sont partis récupérer l'appareil
le matériel ultra sensible et l'équipage
avant que l'incident ne se transforme en
crise diplomatique car déjà ce matin aux
états unis les réactions sont vives
entre je pense que les conséquences
peuvent être sérieuses et que les deux
pays doivent agir très vite pour calmer
la situation
de fait à la maison blanche on explique
suivre la situation d'extrêmement près
d'autant que depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
de george bush les relations entre la
chine et les etats-unis sont assez
tendus au moment où le président
américain doit autoriser ou non la vente
de matériel de très haute technologie à
taïwan vendent à laquelle la chine est
évidemment les opposants il ne passe
j'ai envi ronnement avec le travail
d'une équipe de scientifiques françaises
et américaines qui tentent au cameroun
de purger les eaux d'un lac qui avait
explosé il ya 15 ans provoquant la mort
de 1700 personnes
cette explosion aurait été provoquée par
une accumulation de gaz carbonique dans
ce site lacustre installé dans un volcan
romieu advenant frédéric basket
ces jeunes écoliers camerounais savent
qu'ils vivent sous la menace de nyos
le grand lac dans le cratère d'un ancien
volcan ils sont nés sur ses rives là
même où il ya quinze ans les eaux sont
brutalement entré en colère disent les
anciens
l'explosion qui a eu lieu en 1986 vous
en avez entendu parler
1 oui c'était au petit matin du 22 août
1986 le lac avait pris des couleurs
debout pendant la nuit
une gigantesque bulle de gaz carbonique
venu des profondeurs avait explosé en
surface dans les villages voisins en
quelques minutes
plus de 1700 personnes avaient trouvé la
mort asphyxié ou brûlés en plein sommeil
le gaz mortel s'était répandu partout à
10 km à la ronde
aujourd'hui une nouvelle catastrophe est
toujours à craindre
le gaz pourrait venir par ici dans cette
vallée et vous verriez les animaux
mourir alors il ne faudrait pas
descendre ici
des capteurs de gaz carbonique équipés
d'armes ont été installés pour alerter
la population
mais cette équipe de chercheurs français
et américains s'est lancé dans une autre
mission titanesque tenté de purger nyos
de ses 300 millions de mètres cubes de
gaz mortel du gaz qui se forment à
plusieurs centaines de mètres sous terre
sous le lac en fête des sources chauffé
par le magma fabrique continuellement ce
gaz carbonique il se concentre au fond
de nos os
et quand les eaux en sont saturés
d'énormes bulles montant surface et
explose ça reste un mystère on sait que
le lac se recharge en gaz carbonique
on sait pas d'où il vient force est d'où
il vient c'est qui vient des profondeurs
sinon c'est pas où ils arrivent dans le
lac qui s'étend à fond de façon diffuse
ou ici c'est par des sources discrète
une source plusieurs sources
la solution plonger sur 210 mètres de
profondeur une colonne de dégazage
sortes de pièges pour faire remonter
artificiellement le gaz et l'expulser en
faible concentration dans l'atmosphère
à lui seul ce système va permettre de
purger 20 millions de mètres cubes par
efficace mais il en faudrait quatre
autres pour éviter une seconde
catastrophe
on a voulu c'est arrêter le processus de
recharge c'est à dire bon là on avait on
était en en présence d'une bombe avec
une mèche qui se raccourcit c'est ce
qu'on a voulu c'est couper la mèche
si le projet est financé totalement est
mené à son terme
les habitants pourront quitter d'ici
cinq ans les camps de réfugiés
construits à la hâte et rebâtir sur les
ruines de leur village au bord d'un lac
devenus inoffensifs une première
mondiale amsterdam le mariage officiel
de quatre couples homosexuels présidé
par le maire de la ville en personne ils
pourront avoir la possibilité d'adopter
des enfants selon la loi qui est entrée
en vigueur aujourd'hui se fit redire
tous les yeux sont rivés sur cette
pendule à minuit pile la loi qui
autorise le mariage entre homosexuels
entre en vigueur aux pays-bas pour ces
quatre couples pas question d'attendre
une seconde de plus ce même protocole
que pour les mariages hétérosexuels
échange de consentements et toujours la
même question rituelle franck mais je
voulais vous prendre pour époux
enquêteurs
aux pays-bas la mesure ne choque pas 62%
des néerlandais n'y voit aucune
objection les mêmes droits pour tout le
monde parce que l'amour n'a pas de sexe
en se mariant il acquiert les mêmes
droits et devoirs que les couples
hétérosexuels
grande première la loi néerlandaise
autorise même l'adoption
seule condition pour ne pas générer de
conflit avec les autres pays
l'enfant doit avoir la nationalité
hollandaise les pays bas sont le premier
état au monde à attribuer des droits
aussi large aux couples de même sexe
dans beaucoup d'autres pays
les homosexuels ont tenu des droits qui
ressemble au mariage en france par
exemple vous avez le bac on a pensé à ça
il ya déjà douze ans aux pays bas s'est
dit j'en donne des droits homosexuels
pourquoi pas exactement les mêmes droits
que les hétérosexuels
avec l'application de cette loi les
pays-bas cette honda enregistré environ
10000 unions homosexuelles par an soit
10 % des mariages entre la randonnée à
ski et le sport sous un soleil radieux
cette course de ski alpinisme qui a
attiré plus de 250 concurrents pour la
12e édition du grand béal dans la vallée
du queyras une manifestation
particulièrement populaire dans les
alpes du sud et yens carussi gerard
gallant
dès le coup de fusil chacun affirme sa
différence les concurrents s'élancent
dans des directions opposées une pour
chaque difficultés de parcours pour les
meilleurs c'est la boucle à 2110 mètres
de montée 2362 descentes dans des
paysages somptueux quelques virages
plaisir et beaucoup de maîtrise de leur
randonnée est certains préparent leur
fixation pour la montée avant même la
fin de la descente
on dit que d'autres qui ont choisi un
parcours plus facile prennent leurs
terres
s'amuse et hop
regardez-moi ça comme c'est beau ça
colle du premier coup hemani regarder
plus prêt sert les meilleurs maîtres 40
secondes pour équiper leurs skis de ces
pots synthétique indispensable à la
montée ils ont dû le faire cinq fois
aujourd'hui c'est là aussi qu'une course
se gagne et rigoureux dans tous les
domaines d'autant plus que maintenant la
discipline commence à être un petit peu
plus assise et donc les équipes sont
assez serrés et donc il faut rien
négliger
nordson dont sept noms sept équipes
aujourd'hui c'est monsieur qui s'occupe
de tout il faut dire que madame n'en est
qu'à sa deuxième course marche super
bien mais vraiment extra et en plus je
crois que l'on est fantastique
le grand baie à l'est la course favorite
des débutants un parcours simple et sûr
qui leur permet tout de même de côtoyer
les coureurs confirmés ils étaient
aujourd'hui 220 à l'assaut des sommets
la descente là c'est horrible on a
plusieurs mois j'ai rien contrôler un
c'est très dangereux quand on est en
veille et malgré la peur et les
souffrances
ils ont promis de revenir l'année
prochaine image insolite celle de la
consécration dans les arènes de nîmes du
nouvel évêque du diocèse quelques 7000
personnes y assistaient monseigneur
wattebled avait coordonné par l'évêque
d'arras en présence d'une vingtaine
d'autres évêques venus de toute la
france
le succès est une fois encore au rendez
vous pour le printemps des musées ce
dimanche l'accès était gratuit partout
en france près d'un millier
d'établissements ouverts au public
michel périer et stéphane de sauter se
sont rendus au musée de sèvres jours de
fête aujourd'hui dans les musées de
france où le paysage est décliné sous
toutes ses facettes
les amateurs et les curieux ne boudent
pas leur plaisir au musée national de la
céramique entouré de gigantesques baobab
anvers
et
on peut voir une foire est une forêt de
baobab et baobab comme vous n'en avez
jamais vues des baobabs d'une race très
particulière qui n'existe que dans une
seule ville et ce qui se caractérise par
des troncs très haut très droit et des
petites touches de feuilles tout à fait
en haut ils sont très bien là
l'impression qu'ils sont chez eux ici en
fait il en hiver il ya quatre siècles
différence entre les pros et
millimétriques mais il marche très bien
ensemble
y'a pas de problème
où
il
une création contemporaine bien atypique
dans ces lieux afin de sensibiliser le
public à un autre type de patrimoine
face à ceux des petites nanas qui le
titre c'est regarder moi je vole alors
c'est des petites nanas qui font les
phones et tient bien qu'on les regarde
surtout c'est ça elle fonde la balle en
jeu quoi
un succès pour ce printemps des musées
qui donne la preuve que paysage être
illustrée dans tous les types de
collections qu'il s'agisse d'un ancien
moderne ou bien contemporain avant de
refermer ce journal la détour politique
vers le deuxième tour des élections
législatives partielles qui se déroulait
aujourd'hui en france à toulouse
philippe douste-blazy à cannes bernard
brochand sont donnés favoris tout comme
l'ancien ministre des finances dominique
strauss kahn qui tente son retour sur la
scène politique à sarcelles et nous
retrouvons en direct l bord nicosie la
grande inconnue est évidemment c'est le
taux d'abstention qui avait lourdement
handicapé l'élection du premier tour
tout à fait et béatrice et le taux
d'abstention est resté important
puisqu'on estime qu environ un électeur
sur deux ne s'est pas rendu aujourd'hui
aux y sommes alors les premières
tendances 1 il faut faire attention on a
voté jusqu'à 20 heures ici les premières
tendances donnent dominique strauss kahn
devant ce n'est pas une surprise mais
avec un score beaucoup plus serré que
celui qu'on attendait puisque il
l'obtient sur un bureau test ici environ
54% des voix ce qui est un score qu'on
devrait retrouver finalement sur
l'ensemble de cette circonscription du
val d'oise donc une élection très
probable pour dominique strauss kahn
mais pas réellement une élection de
maréchal dû premièrement l'abstention et
deuxièmement une bonne résistance de la
candidate de droite sophie jacquet merci
allemand nico c'est la vanne cette
édition je vous rappelle le principal
titre l'arrestation sans effusion de
sang s'est tenue à belgrade ce bouddha
milosevic accusé de corruption il a été
placé pour 30 jours en détention
préventive
la communauté internationale considère
que c'est une première étape nécessaire
mais qu'il faudra que l'ancien dictateur
répondent de crimes de guerre et contre
l'humanité devant le tp
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet 20h52 votre film du dimanche the
game avec michael douglas héros heures
40 le dernier journal laurence piquet de
master 47 eur 5 en photo dans les 4
vérités
françoise david ii recevra guy hascoët
que secrétaire d'état à l'économie
solidaire
à 13h le journal de gérard holtz et à
20h le journal de claude sérillon
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2